bonsoir la belle et douce et audrey
byrne et mortelle avait 63 ans france 2
lui rendra hommage ce soir à 22h20 après
envoyé spécial la trêve aura été de
courte durée en irak deux chasseurs
américains menacés par la défense
antiaérienne irakiennes ont riposté
françois mitterrand helmut kohl ont
célébré aujourd'hui à bonn les trente
ans d'une lune de miel entre les deux
pays
nous vous proposerons à la traîne ce
journal un entretien télévisé avec le
président de la république et le
chancelier allemand
le voyage de françois mitterrand en
allemagne était prévu de longue date
le chef de l'état n'a pas voulu leur
portée il faut croire qu'il n'était pas
inquiet outre mesure par le réveil
soudain des monarchistes français on
n'entend plus que depuis quelques jours
et on les a vus ce matin fort nombreux
place de la concorde
deux cent ans jour pour jour après
l'exécution de louis saez la république
a tremblé un instant mais s'est ensuite
ressaisi les compagnies républicaines de
sécurité dit crs n'aurait pas permis le
moindre désordre
reportage de maryse burgot et claude
bernier délice jusque sur le chapeau des
dames comme s'il en pleuvait sur la
place de la concorde
normal ces gens là sont des nostalgiques
de la monarchie
j'estime que la monarchie est un des
meilleurs régimes c'est le meilleur
régime qu'on puisse concevoir et que la
mort de louis seize morts une erreur
tragique pour la france j'ai 67 ans et
j'ai été élevée dans une école primaire
où on ne m'a pas appris l'histoire
véritable on a pu après que louis saez
était un tyran que tous ces nobles
étaient des tyrans est ce qu'on a
maintenant c'est quoi avec 5 millions de
chômeurs il souffre les gens là même les
enfants semblent atteints visage du père
allemand ébloui lorsque l'acteur jean
pierre darasse lit le testament écrit
par louis xiii avant d'ouvrir
mon coeur à ceux qui se sont fait des
ennemis sans je leur en ai buzz et oga
jugé en maître de cérémonie
l'écrivain jean raspail organisateurs de
cette commémoration royalistes ce certes
mais quelque peu chahuté aujourd'hui les
seuls ambassadeurs des états unis
rentrait chez lui
la grande-duchesse bieber
et pour clore cette royale matinée des
centaines de bouquets déposés à
l'endroit même où fut exécuté louis saez
un certain jour de 1793 ambiance
beaucoup moins détendu en revanche
devant le panthéon quelques jeunes
royalistes d'actions françaises étaient
montés s'établissent sur le toit du
bâtiment où depuis la révolution sont
enterrés les grands hommes
alors au nom de ces grands hommes la
police républicaine n'a pas ménagé son
ardeur pour faire dégager les lieux et
pendant ce temps le chef de notre
monarchie constitutionnelle le président
élu célébrer avec helmut kohl à bonn les
trente ans d'une entente exceptionnelle
entre la france et l'allemagne
l'histoire des relations entre les deux
pays a été si sanglante trois guerres en
90 ans que cet anniversaire méritait
d'être fêté avec éclat la construction
de l'europe
les relations économiques très forte
entre les deux pays la coopération
militaire l'identité de vues en
politique étrangère
voilà l'héritage légué par de gaulle et
adenauer qui avait signé le 22 janvier
63 le traité de l'élysée et que leurs
successeurs ont fait fructifier
l'armée allemande perpétue la tradition
du grand couvre-feu qui récompensait ses
généraux vainqueur mais aujourd'hui
c'est en l'honneur des forces françaises
en allemagne
cinquante ans après la guerre les
vingt-cinq mille soldats français est
resté en allemagne travaillent à une
défense commune et à la création d'un
corps d'armée européens dont le général
de gaulle avait donné le ton il y à 30
ans à ludwigsburg
il habitait la jeunesse allemande a
regardé l'europe et à tourner la page de
la guerre
le traité de l'elysée signé avec
adenauer lançait une vaste politique des
changes qui a donné naissance à l'office
franco allemand pour la jeunesse est
bouleversé les rapports entre nos deux
pays
beaucoup d'allemands qui était très fier
d'être européen et il était très peu
fair fiers d'être allemands je me
souviens il y avait un questionnaire à
l'école et on se demandait comment vous
pensez qu est ce que vous pensez de
l'europe et tout ça il y avait 90% pis
voilà l'europe c'est quelque chose de
formidable et ça va vraiment à faire
avec la france aussi qui nous avons
ouvert les portes aujourd'hui 3 millions
d'élèves apprennent la langue de l'autre
et 30 ans après la signature du traité
de l'élysée 4 million et demi de jeunes
français et allemands ont pu se
rencontrer avec la fin du mur de berlin
les échanges scolaires ont pu gagner
l'est de l'allemagne
l'ancienne rda c'est plus que n'en
espérais ceux qui ont signé le traité
franco allemand deux ans seulement après
la construction du mur de berlin
cette entente exceptionnelle entre les
deux pays leur permet aujourd'hui de
résister à toutes les bourrasques
politique monétaire alain de chalvron
qui a interviewé françois mitterrand et
helmut kohl avec d'autres confrères
français et allemand a demandé au
chancelier s'il était partisan d'une
réduction des taux d'intérêt dans son
propre pays
mon souhait est de parvenir à des taux
d'intérêt plus bas mais cela n'est pas
le fait de ma décision ce sera une
décision du taf est indépendante de la
bundesbank et les attaques contre le
franc se sont avérées parfaitement
injustifié car les données économiques
français sont excellentes sur tout à
fait respectable par rapport à d'autres
pays d'europe je dis cela en allemagne
aux allemands et ces turbulences
monétaires étaient parfaitement
injustifié sur le plan français
nous avons la volonté de refuser un
certain nombre des faits que la
spéculation nous promettait par exemple
nous n'avons pas voulu nous ne voulons
pas et nous ne dévoilerons pas à quoi ça
sert de vouloir nous attaquer sans cesse
comme nous avons en plus ce concours
allemand c'est dire à quel point notre
politique voir aboutir à réaliser de
bonnes finances
bien entendu le problème des taux
d'intérêt de l'argent est un domaine
capital il dépend d'organismes
indépendants réellement jeu n'ont pas
grand chose à en dire sinon que si l'on
veut que la
une construction européenne tiennent bon
faudra comme un billard ise nous
diffuserons une longue partie de cet
entretien la fin de notre journal et sa
totalité ce soir à 00h15 au moment même
où françois mitterrand et helmut kohl
s'exprimait la communauté européenne
dénoncé avec leur accord bien sûr les
viols commis par les serbes en bosnie
herzégovine
simone veil faisait partie de la mission
d' enquête européenne sur ces crimes
mais l'ancienne présidente du parlement
européen décidé de quitter cette mission
simone veil estime en effet que la
condamnation politique de ces viols
n'est pas assez forte
les affaires sérieuses commencent pour
bill clinton avec une rupture de la
trêve en irak des avions américains qui
survolait le pays se sont sentis menacés
par une batterie anti aérienne irakienne
ils ont aussitôt riposté françois corner
la patrouille américaine à es16 et un
fantôme prise pour cible ce matin par
les missiles irakiens avaient décollé
dinsi reliques en turquie pour une
mission de reconnaissance au nord du 36e
parallèle lorsque l'un d'eux a été
accroché par le radar de l'abattre
irakienne le fantôme a immédiatement
réagi en tirant un missile sur la
batterie et le f 16 a largué deux bombes
à fragmentation sur l'objectif les
irakiens n'ont pas riposté réaction du
pentagone
peut être que quelqu'un sous-entendu les
artilleurs irakien n'avait pas reçu les
ordres ou que ses ordres n'ont pas été
respectées pour le nouveau secrétaire
d'état warren christopher les etats-unis
ont l'intention de protéger leurs
pilotes dans la zone d'exclusion
aérienne
les iraniens savent pertinemment qu'ils
doivent se plier aux résolutions de
l'onu
ce qui s'est produit aujourd'hui montre
bien la détermination de
l'administration clinton dans ce domaine
tout de même ni washington ni bagdad ne
semble vouloir exagérer l'importance de
cet accrochage qui coïncide avec la
reprise des missions d'inspection de
l'onu en irak ces missions ne semble pas
être remise en cause
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux à
bagdad isabelle bechler et bruno girodon
ils sont arrivés sans encombre 52
membres de la commission spéciale des
nations unies ont pris dans la matinée
un avion de manama jusqu'à l'aéroport
militaire de habbaniya sans anicroche
comme si la crise menace bombardements
des ripostes n'avait pas eu lieu voir
sinon nous sommes arrivés après plus ou
moins deux heures et demie de vol bonne
assistance à l'aéroport de la part des
officiels du rac 1
le personnel direct pierre oued et très
serviable je pense que ce but ce qui
s'est passé pendant ces derniers jours
je peux dire que toute l'équipe est tout
à fait soulagé d'être bien arriver
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont bien reçu oui
j'ai dit qu'aujourd'hui ça s'était très
bien passé
après ce bombardement de lusine dalida
que pensez vous des accusations
d'espionnage lancées par les irakiens
je ne veux pas faire de commentaires là
dessus
ce sont les questions politiques c'est à
new york de réponse et pourtant il ya
deux jours encore les responsables
irakiens accusent est sans ambages
certains de ses hommes d'être des
espions à la solde des états unis
d'avoir transmis par exemple et les
plans détaillés de lusine del nido
bombardé avec une précision extrême
dimanche dernier après le paroxysme de
la tension
l'irak a rebaissé sa garde et laisse
reprendre leur mission aux soldats de
l'onu aujourd'hui est composé de
destructeur d'armes chimiques
les pilotes d'hélicoptère allemand et de
logisticiens d'appui
nous sommes ici pour une mission de
destruction à long terme
on entendait aujourd'hui que bagdad
avait l'intention de mettre quelques
bâtons dans les roues de la commission
quant à sa durée notamment et joe qui
viennent témoigneront donc de la bonne
volonté irakienne bill clinton n'a pas
voulu s'exprimer aujourd'hui sur l'irak
il le fera plus tard
tout occupé qu'il est à s'installer à la
maison blanche dans une ambiance de fête
ininterrompue nous rejoignons washington
nos envoyés spéciaux philippe rochot et
joe thomas c'est la fin de la longue
marche de clinton vers la maison blanche
ses services de sécurité lui avaient
déconseillé de prendre un bain de foule
mais des dizaines de milliers
d'américains ont voulu l'approcher
clinton vient de faire la preuve qu'il
est un président populaire et que ses
fonctions à la maison blanche ne
l'empêcheront pas de continuer le
saxophone qui a contribué aussi à sa
popularité
c'était hier soir pendant le dernier bal
du jour de l'inauguration
mais ce matin les fans du saxo faisaient
leur apparition aux portes de la maison
blanche pour tenter de voir clinton qui
recevait le peuple américain à l'heure
où le conflit avec l'irak revient à la
tête de l'actualité
clinton a voulu quand même respecter
cette vieille tradition qui permettent
au président des états unis d'être à
l'écouté du pays
elle convient parfaitement à un clinton
qui se veut près des préoccupations des
américains
ils ont choisi notre nom parmi 90 villes
cartes postales on se fait un point
d'honneur à venir pour les noirs clinton
est un espoir pour les femmes et aussi
on a parlé de ce que je fais car je suis
professeur et je soutiens ces réformes
de l'éducation
après avoir signé un décret sur les
respect de l'éthique dans la haute
administration clinton devrait en signer
un autre en matière sociale autorisant
les cliniques publiques à donner des
conseils en matière d'avortement
ce que n'ont jamais permis les
républicains en douze années passées à
la maison blanche
ce décret qui assouplit donc
l'avortement sera la première gifle de
l'administration clinton à
l'administration bush mais il est
surtout destinée à montrer que le
nouveau président des états unis tient
ses promesses
en france les cadets de la politique
suive avec un grand intérêt les premiers
pas du jeune président américain s'il
devait y avoir un effet clinton dans
notre pays
bernard kouchner françois léotard et
jack lang en seraient les principaux
bénéficiaires
c'est le résultat d'un sondage réalisé
par l'institut louis harris pour
l'hebdomadaire vsd
bernard tapie sera lui aussi attentifs
le ministre de la ville entend en effet
très présent dans la campagne électorale
il l'a montré aujourd'hui aux côtés de
pierre bérégovoy la rochelle reportage
de jean baptiste près dali et frédéric
de large
moi mon âge quand j'avais ton âge je
veux dire il me semble impensable que
jamais on mu permis d'interviewer un
ministre en exercice avec un appareil
comme le tien ce progrès la montre que
de plus en plus vous êtes le terreau
vous est le ferment d'une société
nouvelle où le citoyen sera de plus en
plus concernés par les choses de la vie
bernard tapie est redevenu ministre
s'efforce se soigner la concordance des
temps
bernard tapie ministre reste bernard
tapie objectif immédiat à la rochelle
cet après midi comme dans tous ses
déplacements
la défense sur le terrain du bilan du
gouvernement à la manière tapis
son horizon c'est bien le combat
électoral de mars prochain
il faut s'activer dit bernard tapie il
le prouve deux heures montre en main
pour visiter un quartier en voie de
réhabilitation un collège quelques
installations sportives et pour donner
un coup de main à michel crépeau député
majorité présidentielle ambiance
campagne et dans cette campagne
chacun son rôle alors celui du chef de
file pierre bérégovoy venu rejoindre son
ministre pour parler de la prévention de
la délinquance et pour préciser si
besoin était les règles du jeu
le ministre de la ville ne doit pas
s'endormir là dessus pas de risque
bernard tapie a bien repris du service
au service de l'alliance des français
pour le progrès et il n'a même pas
commencé sa campagne à marseille
magistrats policiers même combat
autrement dit même grogne contre la
réforme du code de procédure pénale pour
une même raison cette réforme réduirait
à leurs yeux leurs pouvoirs
d'investigation nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion d'évoquer les réticences des
juges d'instruction aujourd'hui
christophe portera à interroger des
policiers à partir du 1er mars
toute personne gardée à vue va pouvoir
s'entretenir dès la vingtième heure avec
un avocat
la présence de ce troisième homme
dérange les fonctionnaires de police
loin de défendre les libertés
individuelles cette mesure selon eux va
freiner leur action d'investigation et
jette le soupçon sur leur profession les
policiers emboîte donc le pas au juge
d'instruction la réforme du code de
procédure pénale ne leur convient pas
ne s'agit pas de protester le texte
existe nous l'appliquerons la loi a été
votée nous l'appliquerons maintenant
nous souhaitons sensibiliser l'opinion
publique et les pouvoirs publics sur
l'application même de cette loi nous
n'avons plus les mêmes moyens légaux de
mener les enquêtes judiciaires dont une
où l'on va être tenu pour responsable de
tous les dérapages au niveau de la
criminalité qui pourraient en découler
certains policiers ont demandé à être
relevés de leurs fonctions d'officier de
police judiciaire
les lettres n'ont pas été envoyés aux
procureurs généraux mais aux différents
syndicats qui les centralise rappel à
l'ordre immédiat du ministre de
l'intérieur
la discussion doit avoir lieu avant une
fois que la loi est la loi s'applique et
je leur demande simplement d'être très
attentifs ce fait que nos concitoyens
qui sont des démocrates ne comprendrait
pas que des fonctionnaires dont le rôle
est de faire appliquer la loi ne la
respectent pas ou appel à la boycotter
pour l'instant 80 juges d'instruction
demandé officiellement à être déchargés
de leurs fonctions les lettres des
policiers pourraient être postés dès la
semaine prochaine
la bourse de paris réagit encore avec
prudence au mariage elle sanofi yves
saint laurent et cela d'autant plus que
la commission d' enquête sur les
opérations boursières s'intéresse de
près aux différentes phases de
l'opération jean pierre métivier
qu'y at il de commun entre l'acheteur
loïk le floch prigent pdg du groupe
nationalisé elf et le vendeur pierre
bergé patron d'yves saint laurent
directeur de l'opéra bastille et proche
du président de la république
réponse des parfums et mardi à l'annoncé
de l'accord les mauvaises langues en
était pour leurs frais je trouve ça
stupide il ya pas de politique là-dedans
elle fait sanofi possède déjà les parfum
nina ricci et yves rocher il lui
manquait une griffe connue dans le monde
entier comme ils st laurent avec ses
flacons opium ou jazz
ma la bourse depuis hier on accueillent
fraîchement l'opération le titre elle
fait sanofi chute de 10%
il retrouve ses cours les plus bas de
l'an dernier et intrigue le marché dans
leurs achats d'yves saint laurent c'est
que ce dossier était à vendre depuis
longtemps aucun professionnel du luxe ne
s'y intéresser et subitement on apprend
à deux mois des élections qu'une
entreprise nationalisée sanofi se porte
candidat à la reprise d'yves saint
laurent et ceci à un prix très
avantageux selon moi pour yves saint
laurent dans cette opération d'échangé
d'actions qui ne coûte pas un sou elle
yves saint laurent est rachetée pour 3
milliards et demi de francs soit un
bonus de 30 pour cent par action alors
que le marché du luxe est en pleine
déconfiture et yves saint-laurent
lourdement endetté nous on est loin
quand même des 5 milliards que demandait
du ton pierre bergé enfin la cob le
gendarme de la bourse qui a déjà ouvert
une enquête sur le titre
yves saint laurent en novembre dernier
va étendre ses investigations sur les
hausses des actions la semaine dernière
juste avant l'annoncé officielle de
l'accord une constatation surprenante
dans un pays comme le nôtre la mortalité
infantile est plus forte qu'on imagine
neuf bébés sur 1000 meurent à la
naissance à la suite de malformations
c'est la raison essentielle mais il
arrive que ces drames soient dus aussi à
l'insuffisance des moyens dans des
petites maternités faut-il dans ces
conditions les fermer question posée par
jean yves perret filippi repos
à eux deux ils assurent la totalité des
350 accouchements pratiqués chaque année
à l'hôpital de saint-amand-montrond et
ses deux gynécologues n'accepte pas les
critiques dirigées contre les petites
maternité sylla leur disparaît les
futures mamans devons faire 50 km pour
accoucher je pense que c'est un faux
procès les petites maternités de
moins de 500 accouchements peuvent être
très bonne équipe et avoir des médecins
compétents avec une technicité
importante mais il est vrai que pour
assurer la sécurité des mamans comme des
enfants le dispositif est lourd outre
les gynécologues et les sages-femmes le
seul pédiatre de l'établissement doit
être toujours joignable les deux
anesthésistes sont de garde
un jour sur deux le prix à payer pour
accueillir n'importe quelle urgence y
compris et les grands prématurés
il faut le temps d'arriver jusqu'à venge
en est à 50 km devant justement des
grands prématurés comme ça normalement
en les accouche pas dans nos services
mais on ne les a couche que dans les cas
où on peut pas assurer le transfert
autre argument des patrons du service
l'accueil personnalisé que permettent
les petites structures les mamans
confirme comme il était le chanteur et
viennent s'était au service bb&t j'avais
pris la nuit les premiers jours à
l'accouchement
je les ai eues j'étais très fatigué
quand j'ai sorti ma maternité que là on
a pris quelques nuits et c'est même bien
reposé preuve que les médecins ne seront
pas seuls à défendre l'existence de leur
maternité
si la menace de fermeture se concrétise
l'imagination de l'homme est tel qu'elle
le dessert parfois il a réussi à mettre
au point un robot jardiniers amateurs de
rouge
le poète savant patrick esther le
déplore lui-même beauté éphémère on les
aime parce qu'elles sont toutes
différentes formes couleurs qui ont
demandé des dizaines d'années de
recherches le fruit d'une expérience
acquise patiemment
l'oeil du jardinier et puis ce geste
minutieux ancestrale que l'on croyait et
irremplaçable la grève du rosier un
petit écusson prélevé sur une tige qu'il
faut délicatement glisser sous les
corses d'un autre rosiers porteuse grèce
mais tout fout l'camp moment monsieur ce
geste n'offrent qu'un débouché beaucoup
trop saisonniers et les jeunes ne
veulent plus le répéter à l'infini
actuellement ce savoir-faire risque de
se perdre alors comme dans beaucoup
d'autres domaines la robotique va
apporter la solution
la pince rotatives du robot présente la
baguette a greffé à l'oeil froid
électronique d'une caméra
le système de vision artificielle
détecte le bourgeon et le présente au
doublé qui découpe l'écusson un bras
mécanique emportent ensuite ce minuscule
morceau de corse jusqu'au rozier
une opération réalisée en un temps
record qui sera bientôt possible en
plein champ puisque le robot entièrement
autonome sera doté de roues bonjour les
six cas cités adieu la poésie des robots
toujours plus de robots mais toujours
moins de boulot pour les
un jour peut-être que seuls les robots
pourront encore au fil de bronze ou
femme
un comble pour le champion du monde de
formule 1 l'écurie williams-renault qui
arrive en tête sur tous les circuits et
risque de ne pas courir la saison 93 s
est inscrit tout simplement en retard
thierry clopeau verra-t-on pour le
premier grand prix de la saison mars en
australie de williams-renault côte à
côte ce soir la réponse est non williams
ne figure pas sur la liste officielle
des engagés
explications l'écurie franco-britannique
archi-favorite certaine avec alain prost
n'a pas déposé ses demandes dans les
délais requis un retard de 24 heures qui
risque donc de coûter cher à l'écurie
championne du monde
le sort des williams renault dépend
désormais uniquement des autres écuries
qui elle seule l unanimité peuvent
décider de réintégrer les deux williams
seul problème 3 et cure et non des
moindres se font tirer l'oreille ce soir
pas de réaction officielle chez renault
pour l'instant reste malgré tout
optimiste mais si par malheur l'écurie
franco-britannique était absente des
circuits ce serait un nouveau coup dur
porté la f1 déjà privé de mansell et
sans doute prochainement de senna une
lettre mal poster et ce pourrait être
l'ultime tête à queue pour un monde de
la formule 1 déjà bien mal en point
elle a représenté le cinéma
international avec éclat pendant de
longues années elle a représenté
l'unicef avec coeur pendant de longues
années
audrey hepburn est morte à l'âge de 63
ans gérard delmas pour la princesse
comme lisa sinatra le conte de fée
commence en 53 avec vacances romaines
film romantique qui lui vaut l'oscar de
l'interprétation hollywood fait une star
de la petite anglaise née à bruxelles
d'une mère hollandaise en 26 film audrey
l'éternel jeune fille élégante n'aura
que des partenaires de légende dont mel
ferrer le premier de ses deux maris et
gregory peck
nike
après le cours d'art dramatique la danse
audrey et mannequin de mode quand la
grande collecte l'a remarqué l'imposant
kerry le théâtre à broadway en 51 trois
ans plus tard elle joue avec le
célébrissime boga des ce film sabrina à
la ville comme à l'écran audrey hepburn
sera toujours habillée par un couturier
à la fois parisien et mondiale hubert de
givenchy
et puis il y a cinq ans la star au grand
coeur touchés par les yeux immenses des
souffrances devient ambassadrice de
l'unicef elle parcourt les grands
cimetières des misères de la planète
exemple somalie l'automne dernier les
corps quel être elizabeth taylor vient
de le dire
dieu a un nouvel ange très beau france 2
lui rendra hommage à 22h30 avec la
diffusion du film charade on y verra
côte-à-côte audrey byrne et gary grant
auparavant vous aurez vu envoyé spécial
paul nahon et bernard benyamin vous
feront découvrir les super mamies filmé
avec amour par patricia charnolé et
jean-louis bouchehr mais avant la météo
de nathalie rihouet et tout en vous
souhaitant une bonne soirée sur france 2
je vous propose d'écouter une partie de
l'entretien que françois mitterrand et
helmut kohl ont accordé à alain de
chalvron il ya d'autres confrères
français et allemand à l'occasion du 30e
anniversaire du traité franco allemand
dans cet entretien qui sera diffusé
intégralement à 00h15 le président de la
république et le chancelier parle
longuement des relations excellentes
entre les deux pays mais aussi de l'état
de l'europe et regrettent notamment que
l'europe ne se montre pas encore plus
forte
face au drame yougoslave écoutons les
un peu stupide que de reprocher à
l'europe qui n'a pas encore de politique
extérieure commune puisque maastricht
n'est pas encore adoptée par deux des 12
pays de ne pas faire comme si maastricht
avait déjà été ratifié
c'est précisément le débat actuel mais
je pense qu'au bout que si le temps pris
un peu plus de vitesse et si basse
triste étaient entrées dans les faits si
nous avions tous ratifié si on
continuait pas de discuter de certains
aspects du traité de maastricht il est
évident qu'il politique extérieure
commune ou convergentes déjà mises en
place aurait facilité nous débarque à
l'égard de l'ancienne yougoslavie est si
basse triste étaient entrées dans les
faits si nous avions tous ratifié
si on ne continue pas de discuter de
certains aspects du traité de maastricht
il est évident qu'une politique
extérieure commune ou convergentes déjà
mises en place aurait facilité nos
démarches à l'égard de l'ancienne
yougoslavie c'est sûr maintenant quand
on parle de l'impuissance de l'europe
c'est un peu vite dit un peu vite dit
car l'ancienne yougoslavie et appartient
à l'europe tout autant que nous mais
d'une europe un peu contrastée elle a
toujours appartenu à des mondes
différents
elle même a été séparée par la puissance
des empires depuis l' empire romain l
empire byzantin en passant par le
camping cet empire romain germanique l'
empire austro-hongrois lempire turc et
combien d'autres choses encore y compris
pendant un moment lempire français
puisqu'une à pognon premier a toujours
sa statue à ljubljana
donc c'est à un pays qui était composée
après la guerre de 14-18 et dont
l'histoire avait été avait été le plus
souvent je le répète contrasté que
l'europe puisse intervenir dans ce qui
apparaissait comme une guerre civile qui
ressemblent aujourd'hui à des guerres
nationale ou ethnique
ce n'est pas facile à traiter c'est pas
facile de se substituer aux gens qui
sont sur place et d'autre part l'europe
unie sur le plan de la politique
intérieure
cette affaire nous sommes pour l'instant
je crois pouvoir le dire le sens rue
e-coli boabab comme des ouvriers qui
sont attelés à une entreprise à la
fabrication d'un échauffement et non pas
finie et les événements eux ils arrivent
mais pendant qu'on prend ce temps là et
comme nous voulons entraîné avec nous
dix autres pays d'europe
ça prend du temps tu sais bien dommage
mais c'est comme ça monsieur le
président on a entendu votre réaction
très prudents quand même sur les accords
de genève parce que corps mais lente
mais engagé oui vous êtes quand même
relativement optimiste je raisonne
jamais perdu ou je ne sais pas comment
les gens réagiront ce que je dis c'est
que c'est un remarquable travail
diplomatique que pour l'instant il a
reçu les accords des gens au fond qui
paraissaient les plus éloignés et qu'il
faut poursuivre dans cette voie est ce
que vous pensez qu'en en même temps donc
cessé ses négociations cette phase
diplomatique se dérouler abouti à
quelques résultats
il faut continuer à brandir la menace
est ce que le faire des choses
raisonnables il faut montrer que nous ne
sommes pas démontré que nous sommes pas
indifférents au drame qui suivent livre
là bas que nous ne tenons pas pour égale
la situation du sud qui souffrent qui en
sont victimes et ceux qui attaquent et
qui agressent et qui exercent les
violences et nous emploierons des moyens
appropriés comme disait diplomate pour
river sont des chevaux
en d'autres termes en d'autres termes
monsieur le président pour préciser
doit-on continuer à travailler à la
résolution sur le respect de la zone
d'exclusion doit-on renoncer à verrières
de aérienne d'exclusion aérienne
doit-on renoncer à l'idée de punir les
criminels de guerre si ce que je pense
que le notion de tribunal qu'il serait
en mesure internationale qui soit en
mesure de juger les crimes contre
l'humanité c'est une bonne idée qu'il
faut préserver
monsieur le chancelier j'enchaîne sur ce
que vous avez dit dans votre discours ce
matin vous avez dit que la renaissance
du nationalisme ne se limite peut-être
pas forcément l'excellent yougoslavie
nous non plus ne se ressemblent pas à
l'abri pourquoi est ce que c'est parce
que les souvenirs dont vous parlez
et remonte à trop loin et qu'une
nouvelle génération d'harry tout cela
que dans les livres d'histoire vous
savez je crois que les allemands ne sont
pas conscients d'avoir vécu dans la
période de paix la plus longue de
l'histoire récente
voilà presque cinquante ans que nous
vivons dans la paix les générations qui
ont vécu les deux guerres sont en train
de disparaître et il n'y a plus beaucoup
d'expériences personnelles voilà
pourquoi ce que nous avons l'année
l'autre essayait de faire ici important
c'est de rendre ce processus
irréversible et là je m'exprime en tant
qu'allemand je n'oublie jamais que
l'unité allemande et l'unification
européenne sont les deux faces d'une
même médaille il ne faut jamais revenir
en arrière même si dans tous les pays il
y a des il y à il ya des gens qui se
complaisent dans un nationalisme un
chauvinisme étroit
vous savez les hommes sont ce qu'ils
sont depuis que le monde est monde
c'est pourquoi il faut veiller à ne pas
rechuter
monsieur le président est ce que moins
de nationalisme dans une robe commune
n'impliquerait pas également davantage
de responsabilités politiques pour le
parlement européen
sûrement sûrement on va dans ce sens on
va dans cette direction
peu à peu ce par le monde devra être
doté de toutes les compétences d'un
internement normal de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique c'est maintenant un
quadragénaire qui est en place depuis
depuis hier vous avez eu je crois tous
les deux des contacts téléphoniques avec
lui que comment comment voyez-vous ces
rapports est que cette nouvelle
administration qui qui connaît peut-être
moins l'europe qui s'y intéressent
traitement le premier soin du président
clinton a été de me dire
avant-hier soir encore c'était le
deuxième conversation que nous avions
qu'il tenait à garder des liens
extrêmement étroits avec la france par
rapport aux problèmes de politique
extérieure qui se pose est celui de
l'irak
celui de la yougoslavie et celui des
débats entre l'europe et l'amérique
il était dans des dispositions
indiscutablement de construction en
commun dans les impératifs de la vie
quotidienne pourront amener des
contradictions et des débats on verra
bien faisons confiance
monsieur le président monsieur le
chansonnier encore une question
personnelle puisque vous êtes liés par
une amitié personnelle quelle est son
utilité dans la politique de tous les
jours je crois que l'amitié personnelle
ne permet pas de faire disparaître les
problèmes lorsqu'ils existent mais cela
fait plus de dix ans sur ce que nous
coopérons très étroitement les liens
sont de plus en plus étroits chaque
année je crois que nous nous sommes
rencontrés plus de 80 fois je crois
qu'il n'y a pas de relation comparables
sur l'échiquier international
nous parlons pas seulement de politique
nous parlons histoire nous parlons
littérature
nous nous sommes aidés et réciproquement
à mieux comprendre le pays du partenaire
c'est une amitié très personnel qui
s'est développée là aussi j'exprime ma
gratitude
si nous étions tous les deux allemands
où tous les deux français
nous serions certainement pas toujours
d'accord se comprend tout c'est pas la
peine d'insister sur le type de
gouvernement a préféré
mais au delà cela même si nous étions
tous les deux allemands et tous les deux
français ça n'empêcherait pas ça existe
avec d'autres de relations de sympathie
de travail en commun dès lors qu'on sait
se dépasser soi-même pour servir des
intérêts généraux de son pays et de
l'europe
d'une façon plus générale du monde tel
que nous le concevons c'est un problème
de civilisation et dès qu'il s'agit de
civilisation vraiment j'ai pas besoin de
grandes discussions avec le chancelier
kohl pour me trouver tout à fait à
l'aise
monsieur le chancelier d'ici deux mois
il ya des élections en france est
vraisemblablement l'opposition va
l'emporter
vous allez donc vous
v avec le président mitterrand d'un côté
et avec un gouvernement avec un premier
ministre et un ministre des affaires
étrangères de droite de l'autre est ce
que c'est pour vous une perspective
difficile ou amusantes amusante
certainement pas le terme est mal choisi
je respecte le choix des électeurs
français
ce n'est pas moi qui me seraient dans la
politique intérieure d'un pays voisin et
ami au demeurant
j'ai fait mes classes j'ai déjà vécu la
cohabitation puisque jacques chirac a
été premier ministre et françois
mitterrand était président de la
république nous avons été ensemble dans
de grandes batailles de la politique
européenne au niveau des sommets
européens nous avons travaillé ensemble
n'a pas compliquer les choses
parfois oui mais il ya eu des situations
où il était compliqué de traiter avec un
premier ministre socialiste ce n'est pas
forcément lié au parti politique au
pouvoir
mes collègues français doivent également
s'accommoder d'un chrétien démocrate
ce n'est pas classique pour un
socialiste je crois qu'il faut faire son
travail
pour conclure l'humiliation vous n'avez
pas posé de questions là dessus faisant
mercier lève